hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition modeling the masters I
believe that the fastest and most
effective way to grow your business is
to model the strategies of people who
have already done what you're trying to
do so today we're going to look at how
three young men who were all coming from
humble beginnings decided to come
together launch a business which became
one of the most successful and popular
websites in the world this is a story of
the founders of Twitter and a top three
lessons and you can learn from their
success Jack Dorsey Christopher Isaac
biz stone and Evan Williams were all on
different career paths when they met and
created one of the world's most prolific
social media sites Twitter in 2000
Dorsey started an online company to
dispatch couriers taxis and emergency
workers this work would soon evolved
into an idea for real-time status
communication stones entrepreneurial
spirit showed at a young age when he
founded a lacrosse team in high school
and coordinated a senior play after the
school decided to cancel it in 1999 a
friend of stones pitched him an idea for
a new company called xanga comm which
they launched together but in less than
a year stone had grown frustrated with
the direction of xanga and moved to Los
Angeles where he worked in television
for a while and wrote a book on blogging
Williams grew up on a farm far from the
high-tech lifestyle he would later
embrace where summers friend you're
getting crops he drifted from working on
the family farm to job to several IT
startups in Texas but finally moved to
Sonoma County California to work with
the technology publishing company
O'Reilly Media all three men were at a
crossroad in their lives and it was at
this crossroad that the three budding
entrepreneurs would come together to
make history both Williams and stone are
working for a new Internet company
called bloggers but eventually sold it
to Google and with those stock options
Williams and stone sold out to start
their own company with that o do a
podcast company was born in late 2006
William stone and several OD employees
form obvious corporation while deal was
acquired by sonic mountain one is one of
obvious his first projects was Twitter
Dorsey was also nearly fascinated with
instant
Bastien approached the company to see if
there was room for his collaboration the
team began a day-long brainstorming
session where Dorsey proposed the idea
of using an SMS service to communicate
with a small group of people within just
two weeks Dorson stone had created
prototype of Twitter total is launched
has his own company in April 2007 with
Dorsia CEO Dorsey sought the young
company through two rounds of venture
capital funding in 2008 Williamson would
become CEO of Twitter with Dorsey taking
a role of chairman of the board although
criticized for lack of a business model
by February 2009 Twitter had become the
third most used online social network
with over 55 million monthly visits the
trio had not designed Twitter to earn
money and for the moment were happy
spending their time and energy on
improving the service rather than
turning a profit namely by focusing on
simplicity constraint and craftsmanship
Twitter meanwhile has grown from being
as a social networking site to important
news distribution tool that gets
listened to around the world people are
no longer using it just to update
friends on their meals of the day
Twitter's popularity spiked for instance
during the Iranian elections with news
of events being reported on site before
mainstream media found out the US
government even asked a company to
postpone a 90-minute scheduled
maintenance outage journey elections in
order to ensure people could continue to
use it to share updates today Twitter is
one of the most widely used daily sites
where people around the world including
the President of the United States by
starting small and by taking steps every
day to grow their business the Twitter
founders were able to go from having a
working demo made in two weeks to
building one of the most successful
websites in the world to help you expand
your business
here are three auction items you can
learn from the Twitter guys
action I'm number one choose
collaboration over competition those the
last time you partner with your
competition might sound like a strange
concept but there's sometimes
opportunities to be had by collaborating
with them as an entrepreneur should be
the best at what you do even if it's
only in a very limited area it means
that for some clients you're the best
option and for others might not be you
might create referral opportunities with
competitors you respect who have a
slightly different skill set I might
also open up chances to bid on projects
together to line the client which either
one of you could get on your own keep an
open mind to collaborating with your
competitors the cofounders of Twitter
have taken a unique approach to their
operations they're choosing
collaboration over competition the
promotion of open information exchange
where it might have once been blocked
and instilling that culture throughout
the company Twitter also worked with
some of the industry's heavy hitters
when it came under attack from hackers
early on Stone likes to call it
nourishing the ecosystem and believes
Twitter has a role to play in
facilitating the open exchange of
information in all its forms the
cofounders believed that collaborating
with a competition will help everyone
out this concept is not unique to the
business world but has continued to work
for Twitter according to Dorsey Stone
and Williams there's a lot we can learn
from smart people out in the world
previous companies I've left before I
left I left because I didn't really like
where the culture was going and I wanted
to leave I was too young to realize that
I could have an impact on changing it if
I didn't like it I could work harder I
think a lot of folks are just wired that
way it's product a or product be like
those blind taste tests there's
something healthy about friendly
competition it's like a scrimmage or
pickup game that's good but the truth of
it is that we're all working together
it's like Coke versus Pepsi I notice the
other day that they're following each
other on Twitter actually I'm number two
make it fun starting running a business
is going to be one of the hardest most
challenging things you ever do in your
life so you might as well have some fun
doing it if you're going to work every
day hating it
you need to change things up find a way
to make it more fun and you not only
enjoy it more you get better results
from it as well from the beginning the
co-founders approached
honey a little differently than most
they didn't know how they're going to
make a profit from it and they weren't
sure exactly who would use it but what
they did know was that they liked using
it today despite the popularity to the
service and the near you know celebrity
status of its founders the three
entrepreneurs have managed to keep
themselves in check why because they're
just having fun
still they continue to enjoy all that
their business is brought them including
a new vocabulary the co-founders found
it funny that some of the words accrued
have made it into the official
dictionary according to the founders
early on someone said Twitter is fun but
it isn't useful I've said neither is ice
cream so what if it's just fun we're
working out odyo but we weren't as
passionate about the podcast and service
as we should have been we weren't using
it and that was a problem
Twitter got started because F give us
some freedom to think along different
lines there are different ways to
approach a startup one thing I admired
about Google is we said this thing is
huge and we're going to kick ass at it
people ask how big is a market for
blogging I said I don't know but if we
make it awesome lots of people would do
it with Twitter there is no market other
than we knew it was cool action I'm
number three key in on culture once you
start building beyond yourself you're
going to have to start thinking about
the culture that you want to create at
your company what is your company
staying for and what values do you want
embody you have an opportunity to hire
people who share those values and you
can create that culture from the
beginning if you don't create it
yourself a culture will naturally form
on its own and might not reflect the
direction you wanted to take so plan
accordingly
Dorsey stone and Williams of trying to
build Twitter into more than just a
microblogging service but into a
superorganism into a company that
cultivates a healthy work environment
and culture as much as it does
technological innovation the Twitter
office itself was even designed to
cultivate an open and fun work
environment there are brick walls high
ceilings and no cubicles employees work
side by side at their stations on modern
furniture breakfast is catered with
everything from soy yogurt to fresh
strawberries then comes lunch also
catered for employees including soups
salads and sandwiches
Thursday at Twitter headquarters is a
particularly special day where a guest
speaker anywhere from a businessman to a
musician jonesing for lunch
employees are then encouraged to tweet
about the lunch as it happens based on
their own personal experiences from
working out other company's Twitter
co-founders decided to place a heavy
emphasis on making sure that theirs was
a company people wanted to go to work
for every day according to the founders
he was very genuinely wants to innovate
not just from a product or
technologically sent according to stone
when thinking about Williams he very
genuinely wants to innovate not just him
a product of technology standpoint but
from a company standpoint for me I've
learned about what it means to focus on
a culture to build social responsibility
and the idea of a company is a
superorganism we focus a lot on culture
specifically we don't want to end up
like that child actor who found success
early and grew up all weird and freaky
we want to remain okay just because we
found success early and in many ways got
lucky doesn't mean we're a bunch of
geniuses it means what it means
so remember choose collaboration over
competition make it fun and key in on
culture to finish up this video I wanted
to share with my favorite true stories
about the Twitter guys and some of the
most inspirational quotes Buddha's been
used by everyday people to report
incidents around the world these
remarkable events have been picked up by
news agencies and reported through local
broadcasts and channels while Dorsey
stone and Williams never thought their
technological innovation would become a
major way of reporting instant news
stories they do joke about sitting
around thinking of new words to describe
the creation after brainstorming they
came up with the name Twitter but also
called the process of delivering
real-time information sending a tweet or
tweeting the inside joke according to
Dorsey is that these two made-up words
are now in the newest official English
dictionary Stone said we never believed
these made-up words that we thought were
just funny ways to describe our
invention would become actual English
words found in a dictionary
thank you for joining me for another
edition Melina masters if you like the
video and you want to see more please
give it a thumbs up below I'd also love
to hear oh you have to think if you want
to leave a comment under the video I
always read those and try to respond
everybody so thank you and we'll see you
on the next episode
you